I'm looking at a picture that somebody
sent me of a Metz desk from when we were
in the studio and we met it really is
disgusting it's like coffee cups and
like stirs and papers and it looks like
an old shirt is on top of your laptop
it's very messy we need to talk about
the deadly bacteria we found on your
workspace you love to deflect but what's
but we're talking about your smell did
you leave you snot rags on your desk
overnight all the time not overnight
sometimes I wouldn't throw them away
right away because I used them Sal and
Richard came to me at one point and
thought my mat was too gross for their
office wow those two slobs I mean yes
yeah if you do gross for Richard you got
a real Prime Richard is disgusting he
doesn't shower right so I swear I'm
disgusting and I Howard I kid you not he
would leave piles of snot rags on his
desk and it would it would flow over to
Richard's side and it would flow over to
my side I would have to take a piece of
paper and pick up the snotty rags
because you would leave them there
overnight
it was like somebody dumped a garbage
pail from a hospital on a [ __ ] desk I
had to take my foot and put like on the
snot rags on top of the desk and like
scoot it all into the trashcan Sal are
you happier now that you share an office
with Steve nawicki and you through my
met out Steve is a pleasure I mean it's
like living with Felix Unger you know
what I do miss about my mat though like
at least once at least once a day or
every other day he would lose his keys
wallet Howard one time he lost his key
card and it was like about 5:30 comes
storming back in he's going nuts he's
all frazzled and he can't find it turns
out it was a dirt pile with tissues
[Laughter]
disorganized and I dunno what people get
the wrong impression me Sal I never like
smelled bad or anything like that no you
just passed your germs on to me on a
daily basis with pops
also you to a ripping ass I mean that's
actually sending fecal matter through
the air on top of like our food and our
drinks and things like that what I'm
saying is we all have our vices oh we
don't honestly we were doing that to
kind of get back at you my master
Richard to call you disgusting is
amazing I mean that is disgusting
I know and that's just the kind of thing
that like follows you forever dude
that's like a piece of [ __ ] saying
you're disgusting
[Laughter]
you